hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the 1858
match between daniel harvest and paul
charles murphy and this is game five to
quickly run you through what happened so
far
uh so morphe traveled to paris he
challenged daniel harvest to a match
he's an extremely strong player
and in order to play a catching a match
against morphy
daniel first challenged morphe to a game
of king's gambit where morphy had the
black pieces and he had to
uh accept the king's gambit at this game
morphy morphy lost and morphy also lost
the first two
official games of the match but then in
games three and four morphe
uh upped his game and he retaliated by
winning both of these games
uh but also after losing the second game
of the match morphy said that harvest
will not win a single game so we're
still we're still uh going through uh
the the match still checking if this
will hold up to be true
uh this is game five and it also quite
quite a nice one so harvest with the
white pieces
uh opens with d4 again harvest goes for
his d4 move
and morphe uh not going for d5 e6 and
some queens gambit stuff uh
a lot like he lost in game one rather he
goes with
f5 he goes for the dutch defense as he
already won a very nice game uh
with the dutch uh back in game four so
here
we have c4 we have e6 by morphe and the
knight to c3 we have knight to f6
everything the same as in the previous
game bishop to g5 and now
if you remember morphy played bishop to
b4 in game three sorry not game for game
three
uh but here we have bishop to e7 now
morphe dv is from the game the two of
them have already played
we have e3 harvest continues to develop
his pieces and
we have castles by morphe uh with bishop
to d3
and now b6 morphe now completed the
development of the king said now he
wants to
develop the queen side the bishop is
coming to this long diagonal and uh
well morphy morphy loves controlling a
lot of space of course
we have knight the g to e2 and morphe
now develops the bishop attacking the g2
pawn
it's not a problem harvest just castles
and now
knight to h5 and it is as of male 8 that
we have a completely new game
so let's see how harvest deals with this
he first trades off a pair of bishops
with bishop captures queen captures and
now knight the g3 offers uh to trade
this night off as well
morphy accepts we have knight captures h
captures and now
d6 and with this d6 move morphe is
probably preparing knight d7 to f6
and then in the future maybe e4 g4 or or
who knows
and here uh it's uh well yeah you could
continue the game in a lot of ways d5
is one such uh one move that probably
can be played you can play queen d2
maybe just queen c2 connect the rooks
uh maybe just queen c2 bishop e2 rook to
d1 the other rogue bringing to c1 maybe
you can bring the queen to h5 so
there are a lot of ideas here that white
can do uh but uh harvest uh
that is now becoming overly aggressive
plays f4 and this just uh
uh well this just creates a lot of holes
for morphe to try and exploit uh for one
thing it
really opens up the h file for the rook
to be used and it weakens these two
squares so now it really makes sense to
bring the knight over to these squares
uh but morphe instead goes knight to c6
uh
kind of a kind of a weird idea because
the knight really belongs on d7 and
and then for example here on g4 uh but
okay
uh we have g4 harvest continues in the
aggressive
aggressive fashion and now knight to b4
morphy puts pressure on the bishop
he was probably expecting bishop to be
one for harvest the part uh
deciding not to part with his bishop and
then morphy could strike in the center
with c5
uh hence the uh the knight maneuver but
here uh
harvest just goes g captures on f5
morphe plays e captures on f5
and now queen to d2 just connecting
rooks still offering the bishop to
morphy
uh but morphy not interested morphy is
saying if you're not going to defend it
i'm not interested in capturing it so he
starts uh bringing the other rook into
the game we have rook 8 to e8
and rook 8 to e1 again not really
interested in
uh defending this bishop and now morphy
just goes queen to
h4 now with ideas of rook f6 rook h6 and
then
maybe queen to h1 with some very nasty
ideas so here
bishop the b1 now harvest decides that
he will
uh save the bishop but also he wants to
activate the knight so
it does make sense to defend this spawn
and it's
very interesting how morphy will get to
this b for knight into the game to be
useful at all so here
rook to e6 morphe is ready to bring the
the rooks into the attack
and the queen to f2 now harvard offers a
queen trade which morphe declines queen
to h5
we have five by harvest pushing the rook
back and now
rook to h6 and now it looks very scary
uh rook acquaintance h1 is the threat of
checkmate however just
queen to f3 by harvest uh offering a
queen trade queen to g3 also
possible harvest decides to offer a
queen trade right away
and now queen h2 isn't really all that
impressive uh harvest just goes back and
if queen to h4
uh you can again just go back with king
to g2 you could also play
king to e2 you could also play g3 it's
not a problem if the queen persists you
can just block it
uh this is perfectly fine for white
because the knight and bishop aren't
really a part of this game so morphy
first needs the
needs to deal with that queen to h2 also
doesn't help
help so morphe instead goes queen to h4
uh just waiting preventing the king from
uh from escaping uh you know
uh to the queen side and now we have a3
pushing morphy's knight back
knight to a6 and now uh even b4
so this is a very very strong move by
harvest and shows what uh what a great
positional player he is
uh because he knows there is no danger
for him on the king side the bishop
isn't really doing all that much and now
he wants to render this knight useless
by playing b4
takes away the c5 square from this
knight and now morphy will
have to do what he should have done all
along he needs to bring the knight uh
back to b8 and then start over knights
to d7 knight to f6 and then knight
g4 or e4 depending on what black plays
but this was the
uh or the route that knight should have
taken uh but okay
morphe starts with knight to b8 and now
knight to e2
this knight can now come to e come to d4
maybe to e6 but also can be used to
help out the defending the king's side
we have knight to d7 by morphe
and now not going for this queen to g3
uh trying to trade queens but rather
knight the g3
and now the knight is covering the h1
square also the king can now escape here
as the f2 square is not covered by the
black queen
uh also the f5 pawn is under attack
knight captures an f5 definitely a
threat which would uh
endanger both the queen and the rook so
morphy just defends it with the g6
and now king to f2 now harvest starts to
bring his king to the queen side where
it's much safer
knight to f6 by morphy and now rook to
h1 and it seems like morphy's queen is
trapped
but not really he does have a some
squares uh that are available to him uh
but you don't really
have the g4 square because if you go to
g4 just rook characters on h6 you've
hung a rook
uh so this is the only move morphe has
it at his uh
disposal and that is knight the g4 with
check
so freeze up the f6 square for the queen
we have king to g1
uh and now comes queen back to f6
uh we have rook captures on a6 knight
captures on h6
and now queen back to d1 re-maneuvering
the queen into the game
and now uh harvest got rid of morphy's
attackers on the kings side and
will enjoy i will enjoy a very nice game
before because morphe still needs to
decide what to do with this bishop here
so knight to g4 morphy brings the knight
back into the attack and now
queen to d2 uh we have queen to h4
again going for this attack but now just
knight to f1
very nicely done the knight is now
defending the h2 square
the g3 square is defended the e3 pawn is
defended so this is uh
one excellently placed knight so rook to
e8 putting additional pressure on the e
file and now
g3 just pushing the queen back we have
queen to h3
and now again the problem is you could
go queen to g2 but it's not all that
great here amorphy could just capture
and after king captures play c6 and
suddenly this bishop comes alive and
this is not something
that white should even allow so instead
harvest again with a very strong
positional move
and that is b5 he takes away the c6
square from
uh morphe's uh from uh morphy spawn and
now the bishop will have to find a
different way to get back into the game
so knight back to six by morphy now
trying to shift the knight over to
after the center of the board and now
just queen g2 offering a queen trade
morphe now accepts with queen captures
king captures and now
a6 morphe now tries to create a
breakthrough here on the queen side
a4 defending this pawn with captures
captures and now of course you have to
bring your rook into the game somehow
and
that uh and that will be done by the a8
square so rook to a8
and now knight to d2 there are some
weaknesses here like the backwards c
pawn backwards
pawn and harvest needs to defend those
so here rook to a3
putting pressure on the e3 pawn and just
e4 getting rid of the backward spawn so
both morphe and harvest playing this
game
uh really really on a high level so far
the only thing
uh uh that was a little weird was
harvest uh
harvest over aggressive f4 idea and
morphe taking the
really really long route with the knight
instead of just three moves
morphy did like 30 moves so here f
captures on e4 morphe grabs in the
center knight captures knight captures
and the bishop captures so a lot of
trades here in the center
morphe now goes after the undefended
pawn rook to c3
and now bishop to f3 a very sneaky idea
uh by by harvest saying that okay if you
capture my c4 pawn i have this
rook to e8 check king f7 and rook to b8
and
morphy's bishop is trapped so not only
is morphy's bishop trapped that it can't
go anywhere because of the pawns and
light swords but now it will also be
captured and it doesn't help to
harass the white king for example check
king here and now attack the bishop
because
the bishop just moves now the king
defends the bishop and next move you're
gonna lose this bishop so
not a lot of fun so instead uh after
this bishop to f3 morphe spots that uh
the the c4 pawn isn't really up for
grabs he goes king to f7 instead
and now comes rook to e4 harvest now
defends the pawn
and now the material is completely equal
the bishops are of the exact same color
and uh morphe uh it it doesn't seem like
there can
be any chances of winning this game but
okay never hurts the tribe bishop to c8
morphy
uh tries to bring the bishop back into
the game bishop to f5 is the idea
and here harvest should play g4 it's a
really ugly looking move but sometimes
ugly is necessary and here you prevented
the bishop from coming to f5
and you will you will have to try
somehow for example morphe could play h5
g captures and then bring the bishop to
f5
uh but at least you you will get get
something for it instead after this
bishop to c8 bishop to e2 was played
now adding another defender to the pawn
here but now morphy gets to activate his
bishop bishop to f5
we have rooked at d4 and now now morphy
plays h5 and now g4
will no longer be an option so king to
f2 and now king to f6 by morphe
we have rook to d2 and now comes bishop
to c2
morphe is now going after the c4 pawn
and he's going this way
and here king to e1 again harvest with a
very very tricky idea
uh he wants to meet bishop he wants to
meet bishop to b3 with rook to d3
and morphy doesn't like this but it's
actually good for morphy
uh but it's not all that simple because
if morphe goes after the pawn harvest
goes rook to d3
now morphy will not be able to capture
this because just bishop cap
rook captures bishop or if bishop
captures rook captures rook and of
course if rook captures uh then
bishop captures rook and the c4 pawn is
defended
however here you can still gain a
winning advantage with rook to c1 check
but it's uh
not a move everyone can find uh and
after
king to d2 attacking the rook now you go
rook to c2 with check king to d1 and
rook captures on e2 so it's not all that
uh
uh difficult but uh you know and now of
course
if if the rook is captured bishop
captures on c4
pinning the rook next the next movie
you're gonna capture and you're just
gonna grab all of these spawns you're
already up upon so of course in a king
and pawn end game this is completely
winning
so the rook cannot be captured you will
have to go after the bishop and now
rook to g2 and slowly but surely you
will win at least uh
upon here and gain a winning winning
advantage for for example king e1 king
f5 you're going to go after this this
pawn
king f1 you're going to shift your
attention to this pawn and after
this pawn is defended for example you're
going to play rook to c3 again go after
this pawn
king f2 defending now king to g4 and
finally black will
win the spawn in the game so it's quite
a lot of moves but
uh uh you know it was definitely
possible morphy's first inclination
turns out to be correct
but morphe finds a different way uh he
plays bishop to e4
first and now now it it's a it's a bit
of a different game
as the g3 pawn is still under attack so
harvest defends it
and only now king to f5 uh we have rook
to a2 by harvey it's now going probably
after the c7 pawn which would be a big
deal
but now h4 morphe weakens the f4 pawn
we have g captures king captures and
rook to a7 going after morphy's
backwards c7 pawn
but now morphy goes rook to h3 he's
ready to capture the pawn on h4
but that's only the one little part of
the threat
there are other parts as well because
here you most definitely do not capture
the c7 pawn but that's exactly what
harvest did
now feel free to pause the video here
and crush uh harvest
again for his great insolence while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
only winning move in the position and
that's not
rook captures on h4 most definitely not
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's
rook to h2 with check and now you see
the horror
if king to g1 king to g3 and there is no
defense against rook the h1
checkmate uh it doesn't really matter
what you do you you could
of course prolong it by some silly moves
but we're not going to cover that
uh and if of course if you go the other
way around if you go king to e1
then morphe plays king to e3 which was
played in the game
and it was in this position on move 54
that daniel harvest resigned the game
which makes it his
third loss in a row and now morphy
finally takes the lead in the match
morphe is now leading three to two
and this is the position from the
thumbnail and also something if you're
new to chess that you always need to
remember
uh if you have your king opposed to your
opponent's king
of course that means these three squares
are these three squares are covered and
any check by rook will be just deadly
rook to h1 check
and there's really not all that much you
can do okay here you can block with the
bishop but you can then just attack the
bishop and it's not a problem
it doesn't really matter uh what what do
you play here for example if you try
something like rook to a7 to
bring the bring it back into the game
you could play rook to h1
check and then try and uh harass the
bishop but it's much much faster to play
rook captures i need to check
and that's just it there's really no way
to defend this and if you want to move
the bishop
to prevent this what do you do there's
really no good square for you to move it
let's
say try bishop to g4 then rook to h1 is
indeed
checkmate now the problem is when even
if the bishop wasn't here
that's basically what i wanted to tell
you even if this bishop
isn't here the king is covering these
three squares
and then you have the bishop behind the
king also a very useful thing to know
the bishop covers these two squares as
well so usually if it was just a king
and a rook against your king you could
step sideways and then avoid being
checkmated but the bishop covers one
extra square
from each side and it doesn't matter if
white to get some
in with his king it's still going to be
rook to h1 with checkmate
so morphy wins this game uh takes the
lead in the match and uh
well as it usually happened in those
days when one player started losing he
started uh
uh well calling sick and said that he
needed uh
to rest so here harvest requested 10 day
eight to 10 days of
resting so he you know recollects
himself and then he can continue the
match
but interestingly morphy of course
allowed this but under one condition
morphy said yes you you are more than
welcome to rest but after we resume play
we will play every day sunday's excluded
until we finish the match so harvest
agreed to this and staunton
uh even uh wrote about this in his call
and he mentioned
everything that was happening as it was
quite a quite a big match and also
staunton was very interested in how the
match will turn out as uh
well he we do know that staunton is the
final boss
of this saga or so it would seem uh so
yeah
but interestingly uh after harvest
requested this timeout he still spent
every day uh in in cafe de la regents
playing uh
chess uh often up until midnight and
often uh
uh with a franc per game uh betting
against players and making money so he
didn't really
take this time to well get better but
instead he just continued doing what he
usually does maybe
he thought maybe morphy would lose
interest or maybe you know morphe would
stop playing so well
uh because who knows what was going
through his mind
uh but yeah we're going to talk about
this a little bit more because
there's one more game coming up and then
there's also a very funny story coming
up
after that game so this was game five
hope you guys enjoyed it
and hope you're enjoying the the morphe
saga uh so far if you're just joining us
you can check the link in the
description below and you can start
the morphe saga from the beginning so
you can catch up to it as there's
quite a lot to learn in there about the
the great paul charles morphe
so uh that's it hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank
a mystery person johannes que pastos
derek king gerhart homer and john monk
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day